michigan and colorado say they will be
able to vaccinate all of their adult
residents sooner than the biden
administration's plan for a may 1st
target date
the announcement comes as a new
milestone is reached more than 101
million doses of
covid19 vaccine have now been
administered nearly 20 percent of all
americans
have received at least one shot while
the average number of new cases is down
about
13 percent from this time last week
health officials are warning now is not
the time to let our guard down against
the virus
tom hansen is at around the clock
vaccination site here in new york city
with more tom good morning good morning
dana well this vaccination hub is open
24
7 to help push toward the goal of fully
vaccinating
5 million new yorkers by june and
nationwide we set a record yesterday
giving out nearly 3 million doses
according to the cdc but even with all
of this positive news
there are still plenty of reminders of
just how far we have to go
the maskless crowds partying in
charleston south carolina may
look like a return to the old days but
quick condemnation from health officials
tagged thursday's events
as a possible layup for a return to a
surge
very foolish very unwise against public
health guidelines
and these are super spreader
settings it all began after governor
henry mcmaster lifted the 11 pm
curfew on selling alcohol and
requirement to wear masks in restaurants
they assume that because governors lift
restrictions
it's okay to go out and party like it
was 2019.
at least 15 states now no longer have
restrictions on most
or all of their businesses including
florida where spring break on the beach
now looks like spring breaks of a
pre-pandemic past
we decided to get away from the cold and
into the sun but march madness should be
a tip-off that the pandemic
remains players on three top men's
basketball teams tested positive
forcing their teams to withdraw from
conference tournaments
worse this week the virus claimed the
lives of more than 1100 people each day
on average in the u.s
and the variants of the mutating virus
are coming on strong
it turns out that some of these
mutations actually change the behavior
of this virus
in a way that makes it more infectious
or more serious
in a report prepared for tomorrow's 60
minutes dr
francis collins of the national
institutes of health talks about the
seriousness
what wasn't predictable for me anyway
was that there would be so many copies
of this virus
that even a slow evolutionary process
could in just a matter of a few months
produce some viruses that we're worried
about it's no wonder why health
officials are still
sounding the alarm we need to get
everyone vaccinated
as soon as possible we need to keep our
masks
on we need to socially distance and so
forth
for the government's part vaccination
efforts keep expanding
more than 2 million shots are given out
each day to an eager
public i hope everyone gets vaccinated
because
i think that's the only way we can go on
if everyone can do just that little
thing
i think it will help the whole country
in louisiana where restrictions remain
our cbs affiliate wwl asked viewers to
share their dreams
about what they'd do first when it's
safe i'm writing travel
boxing matches theater i'm gonna party
like
it's 1999.
i think we can all relate to that and
while they're still very far to go
before getting the country fully
vaccinated
some more positive news in the last
month vaccinations have ramped up
by 40 percent michelle yeah a lot of
people
are going to be quoting prince from now
on partying
like it's 1999. tom thank you so much